you know the only thing missing from the
delight i find in tending to plants is
the joy i find in eating sweet treats
[Music]
what's up everybody i'm merle hi i'm
rachel i am a truly insane but proud
plant lady i like plants i like the idea
of plants being around i just want other
people
to tend to them we are here today
because tasty and wilton have partnered
to make some super cool activity kits
we're gonna have fun it's gonna be fun
should we see what we're working with
let's do it all right ready one two
three
whoa
whoa that's really cute i'm a little
nervous because i don't do things like
this very often but i have faith in
myself let's tear into this thing yeah
whoa
what do we have here frosting
don't sprinkles
these fancy schmancy little graham
crackers let's do this thing so
instructions
step one cut cardboard into a strip
that's the last time i've done
crafts like this knead or massage the
icing pack
finesse your icing rachel become one
with the process
here we go oh we're cruising now baby yo
look at that okay oh my god she's so far
ahead of me there we go now we're
cooking with gas she's a pro this is a
very possible
um activity to
to do
as you can witness here i am just a
little bit crafty challenged enter boxes
come in all shapes and sizes the
instructions say that it takes four
hours for this thing to dry how are you
done right now i'm gonna go
get some lunch
cool good luck it's fine things are
great we'll see you in four hours
what up rach oh hello have you been here
this whole time
maybe
but
i ended up using a little twine very
crafty is new this thing could survive a
hurricane first thing we're gonna do
need fondant oh the fondant oh wow this
mold fast
okay so now we roll the fondant with our
rolling pin look who's in the lead now
merlin whoa
rolled out
boom
okay so i'm gonna do five of each of
these little leaves i need my scissors
again
oh this is like making christmas cookies
oh it does remind me of that i think
this would be fun to do like a little
adult crafting circle can you buy this
already yeah it's definitely in stores
now all right so we've got our little
adorable cutouts nice work so now we get
to try the marbling yes i'm excited
start with two to one ratio of each
green shade roll colors into equal
length logs it's ready to go
okay oh man yours looks good
[Music]
oh and now i'm gonna fold it one more
time now we gotta roll these out into
our little succulents this is like the
most fun part this is the moment we've
all been waiting for it yeah i know i
have keep those thumbnails rolling oh
look at this cutie
okay so we're flipping her over yeah so
very careful over surprise
surprise
so satisfying i love it immediately
sprinkle icing with brown sprinkles
until covered you got it
this is like that fresh mulch let's see
position succulents leaves and candy
rocks as desired
i have an idea for my garden me too i
want to go for a garden you would like
to stroll through
after a long day's work i want you to
look at this garden and think not a
shrub out of line
oh no i'm gonna run out of rocks real
soon that was my concern okay i'm
changing my plan here i'm covering up
all of the handiwork mishaps i've made
oh i see that
and
you're done i'm done
[Music]
hands off we're done it's over rachel
you've got some sprouts coming out of
the middle of yours it looks like you
got some newborn propagated succulents
i'm impressed by your knowledge all
right let's bring in the judges bring
them in let's finish this
[Music]
look at these little ones i like that
this one has like a little path it's
taking me on a little adventure if you
see these little details on the side um
those are so cute yeah but this one's a
little bit more like the road less
traveled like it's a little it has some
symmetry but it's also like find your
own way if i had to pick a winner it
probably would be this one because it's
just well thought out i think the
succulents are bunched well together i
like that one a lot but i feel like it's
really close to the box and i like how
this person kind of did their own thing
i like this one because it's like more
open there's like those little kind of
creative little feels in there but i
think i'm gonna go with this one just
cause it's like a little more
diversified in its look okay listen no
matter what happens we both did a great
job and i had a lot of fun me too
but who won i really need to know yeah
sorry i'm trying not to rub it but i'm
really excited it's okay they didn't
appreciate my little kale plants
blooming in the middle i would do this
with my friends i would buy this for my
mom i'm positive that i'm gonna buy this
for my nieces and nephews for christmas
you should totally pick one of these up
and make it at home and if you do please
tag us so we can admire your little
succulent gardens i will appraise them
myself thank you so much for watching
i'm sorry we're insane but i'm really
not that sorry at all
you